EQUIPMENT FROM ALL AROUND THE
WORLD.
TUCKER?
>> Tucker: SEEMS LIKELY.
THANKS SO MUCH FOR THAT REPORT.
SO THE LAB IN WUHAN WAS UNSAFE
AND IT WAS OBVIOUS TO AMERICANS
VISITING THERE TWO YEARS AGO.
BECAUSE OF THE PRACTICES THEY
ARE THE CHINESE MAY HAVE
UNLEASHED A GLOBAL PANDEMIC ON
THE REST OF US.
HERE’S SOMETHING REMARKABLE AND
UPSETTING.
THE WORK AND THAT LAB INCLUDING
ITS RESEARCH INTO DISEASE
CARRYING BATHS WAS FUNDED IN
PART BY YOU.
TAXPAYERS TO THE NATIONAL
INSTITUTES OF HEALTH.
HARD TO BELIEVE THAT’S TRUE BUT
IT IS.
CONGRESSMAN MATT GAETZ
REPRESENTS FLORIDA AND HE JOINS
US TONIGHT.
THAT’S ONE OF THOSE STORIES, IF
YOU HAD SAID THAT OUT LOUD A
WEEK AGO I MIGHT HAVE JUST
MISSED YOU BUT IT’S TRUE.
HOW DID THAT HAPPEN?
>> I’M AGAINST CHINESE RESEARCH
IN OUR COUNTRY, BUT THE NIH
GIVES A $3.7 MILLION GRANT TO
THE WUHAN INSTITUTE OF VIROLOGY
AND THEY THEN ADVERTISE THAT
THEY NEED CORONAVIRUS
RESEARCHERS AND FOLLOWING THAT
CORONAVIRUS ERUPTS IN WUHAN.
WHAT’S TROUBLING TO ME IS EITHER
CONSPICUOUSLY OR MIRACULOUSLY
THE WUHAN INSTITUTE OF VIROLOGY
IS ABLE TO SEQUENCE A VIRUS ON
JANUARY 2ND.
CHINA DOESN’T ADMIT TO THE VIRUS
EXISTING UNTIL JANUARY 9TH AND
THEN THE WUHAN INSTITUTE OF
VIROLOGY DOES NOT RELEASE THIS
IMPORTANT SCIENTIFIC INFORMATION
TO THE WORLD UNTIL JANUARY 12TH.
SO I’D BEST AMERICANS ARE
FINDING PEOPLE WHO ARE LYING TO
US AND AT WORST, WE ARE FUNDING
PEOPLE WHO WE KNEW HAD TROUBLE
HANDLING PATHOGENS AND BIRTHED A
MONSTER VIRUS ONTO THE WORLD.
>> Tucker: BY THE WAY, CHINA
IS ABOUT TO ECLIPSE US IN TERMS
OF THE SIZE OF ITS ECONOMY.
IF IT HASN’T ALREADY, AND IT
SEEMS LIKE IT MIGHT HAVE.
EITHER WAY, WHY ARE WE SENDING
ANY MONEY TO CHINA FOR ANY
PURPOSE?
>> THERE IS A FAR TOO COZY
RELATIONSHIP BETWEEN U.S.
RESEARCH AND CHINESE RESEARCH
BECAUSE THERE ARE SOME
INSTITUTIONS IN OUR COUNTRY WHO
REALIZED THE SHORT-TERM BENEFITS
OF CHINESE CASH.
BUT THAT DOESN’T EXCUSE OUR
GOVERNMENT AND WHAT SHOULD
REALLY TROUBLED VIEWERS AS THIS
IS AN ACTIVE GRANT, NOT
SOMETHING OF YESTERYEAR.
I CALLED ON SECRETARY AIDS ARE
TO IMMEDIATELY HALT THIS GRANT
TO THE WUHAN INSTITUTE OF
VIROLOGY.
THEY HAVE NOT BEEN HONEST AND
WORSE THEY’VE BEEN NEGLIGENT TO
THE POINT OF MANY DEATHS
THROUGHOUT THE WORLD.
>> Tucker: THIS WILL LIVE ON
FOR ALL TIME AS A METAPHOR FOR
OUR INCOMPETENCE AND
SELF-LOATHING.
IT LOOKS LIKE THERE IS EVIDENCE
THAT THIS VIRUS ESCAPED FROM THE
LAB.
WE DON’T KNOW THAT THAT HAPPEN
BUT THAT’S CRAZY SUBSTITUTION.
COULD SOMEONE END OF THE FUNDING
TO THE VIROLOGY?
>> I THINK SECRETARY As ARE
COULD DO IT WITH THE STROKE OF A
PIN AND CERTAINLY IT’S
CONSISTENT WITH THE FANTASTIC
NEWS THAT PRESIDENT TRUMP GAVE
US TODAY, THAT THE UNITED STATES
WILL NO LONGER BE A PATSY FOR
THE AMERICA LAST ORGANIZATIONS
LIKE W.H.O. AND WTO.
WE’VE BEEN TAKEN ADVANTAGE OF IN
THOSE GLOBALIST INFRASTRUCTURES
FOR FAR TOO LONG UNDER BOTH
REPUBLICANS AND DEMOCRATS.
PRESIDENT TRUMP GIVES US THE
CHANCE TO LIBERATE OURSELVES
FROM THIS AND PUT OUR PEOPLE,
OUR HEALTH AND OUR ECONOMY